ize Gary Myers he's a writer for the
athletic as a terrific column out about
the state of Eli Manning his situation
with the Giants he's also the author of
the book how about them Cowboys and Gary
joins me here on the show Gary one of
the the sentences that jumped off the
page when I was reading your column
about Eli Manning was that you looked at
this past draft and forgive me if I'm
phrasing it wrong a franchise changing
mistake drafting sake one Berkeley over
Sam Donald but my only issue with that
is I don't really know for sure that Sam
Donald is a great quarterback what do
you think well Chris I think we saw
enough from Donald I have to came back
from the foot injury in the last month
assume with the right coaching next year
that he's ready to take a big leap
forward and you know as far as the
Giants are concerned it was the first
time they were picking in the top five
since 2004 it happened to be in one of
the best quarterback drafts at least
going into it that we thought we you
know the NFL had in a long time and the
Giants had a quarterback who turned 38
years old yesterday and you just don't
get that many opportunities to take a
leak quarterbacks and even though
cyclone barkley was clearly the best
player in the draft and he plays a
position that has a short shelf life in
the NFL and as great as he was this year
the Giants won five games and as
greatest will be next year
if he line Manning is the quarterback
they won't win more than five games so
my feeling is that in order to set the
franchise up for the future even though
there might not have been the instant
gratification this year that they had to
take the quarterback okay but if they
draft let's say Dwayne Hoskins with that
top-10 pick this year and they bring
Manning back for another year turns out
Haskins can play is it still a mistake
well then the benefit of you know
another year of results we can tell I'm
not sure that you know it's very early
in the process with Haskins now to say
where he would rank versus say Mayfield
and Arnold
Allen and rosin from last year I mean
Lamar Jackson is only one of the five
who picked in the first round was in the
playoffs this year but nobody had him as
a top ten pick so we're limited to the
four guys that were picked in the top
ten Chris at this point I'm not sure
where Haskins would have ranked in those
two among those players now it could
turn out by the time the dress comes
around the end of April that Scouts will
be saying well you know Haskins was in
that group he would have been the first
player pick we just don't know that
right now so to me and I listen the
other part about it is we don't even
know first of all if the Giants like
Haskins and secondly they're picking
sixth the top five teams are not going
to take a quarterback but somebody can
easily jump over the Giants to get
Haskins if the Giants really like even
if the Giants really like them they like
might not get him at six and I don't
know that the Giants are in a position
where they feel they can give up quality
draft choices to move up for a
quarterback so they might not get him
anyhow okay so there is no as we just
point out natural successor to Eli
Manning at this point we don't know if
they're even gonna draft a quarterback
they probably will but we don't know yet
kyla let-up doesn't seem like he's the
natural successor Eli Manning why is it
even a discussion within the Giants
about bringing Eli Manning back
Wellman said the other day he doesn't
know what the field is gonna be in this
offseason which means his nick foles was
gonna smooth this nick foles going to be
available we think he is
Joe Flacco do they consider Flacco who
is and I turned them kind of a younger
version of Manning at this point in his
career he'll likely get cut by the
Ravens but is that really an upgrade do
they like Teddy Bridgewater because Pat
Sherman was around him for a couple
years in Minnesota although Bridge war
didn't play them because he was hurt you
know do they like him enough to kind of
bring him in and I wouldn't even call my
transition quarterback at that point
because he's a young guy so I think that
before they commit to Eli they want to
see what's out there
but realistically when you're trying to
project Chris with what's going to
happen here
I think Eli of you back I think they'll
renegotiate his contract or restructure
his contract because this cap head is
about twenty three million dollars this
year so they might add an a year onto it
just a cap purposes and keep him around
even if they were able to get it you
know Haskins or a drew lock or daniel
Jones they might want to keep Eli in the
role that Kurt Warner played for Eli in
two thousand four so you know as we're
sitting here on what is today January
what the forth my guess would be that
Eli would be back in in some role next
year likely is the starter at at least
the beginning of the season and unless
the you know foals becomes available and
they and the Giants are in love with
them because you have to remember also
the connection between Shermer and foals
is that Sherman was the offensive
coordinator in Philadelphia in 2013 when
foals had that year we threw 27
touchdowns and two interceptions so I
know he has a great you know affinity
for Nick Foles that's the one I would
keep an eye on because I'm pretty sure
he's gonna be a free agent Eagles aren't
gonna want to pay him twenty million
dollars and it's a mutual option so that
even if the Eagles pick up the option
foals can buy his way out for two
million dollars and try to get a much
bigger contract on a team that he'll be
the unquestioned starter talking to Gary
Myers our writer for the athletic is the
author of the new book how about them
Cowboys available everywhere let's talk
about the Cowboys for a minute Gary you
know going into this playoff game
they're home they've got a great running
back they've got a high-level defense
they just got a new star wide receiver
they're playing the Seahawks anything at
stake in a game like this for Jason
Garrett everybody has assumed at this
point that Garrett will be back next
years the last year was contract and
then he'll get an extension but I'll
tell you what I'm not completely sold on
that that if if the Cowboys were to lose
tomorrow night and if it was a really
bad loss where the offense just
completely shuts down which is
possible I don't think it's a given that
a wildcard loss at home guarantees that
he'll be back next year now granted it's
going to be difficult to fire a guy
after one wins 10 games and wins as you
know second division title in three
years but the Cowboys I think at this
point I think the Cowboys have to
evaluate Garrett on postseason success
it's been 23 years since they were in
Istanbul and that's the last one they
want obviously and I know in researching
this book and spending your 5 hours over
three different interview sessions with
Jerry Jones how much it it irritates him
and aggravates him that it's been such a
long time since they've been in the
Superbowl
and if Garrett can't get this team two
or three rounds deep into the playoffs
he might feel he's taken him as far as
he can and it's time for a change I I
can't say I think that's likely but I
think it's on the table for sure always
great to talk to you Gary I appreciate
the time all right Chris take care
thanks very much that's Gary Myers the
writer for the athletic his new book is
called how about them Cowboys which is
available everywhere for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]